donald trump ha demostrado no tener
intención de ponerse la fácil a las
autoridades federales después de que el
fbi registrará su casa de mar a lago el
ex presidente de eeuu envió un documento
a un tribunal de florida el documento
contiene varias exigencias en primer
lugar el nombramiento de un experto
independiente dicha persona debe revisar
los documentos incautados y determinar
si pueden utilizarse en la investigación
según la defensa de donald trump algunos
de los documentos son confidenciales
porque abordan temas entre un cliente y
su abogado según el 'new york times' el
ex mandatario ha almacenado más de 300
documentos clasificados en mar a lago
pero el documento enviado también tiene
un tinte político
los abogados del multimillonario afirman
que el gobierno de eeuu trata a su
cliente de manera injusta según ellos se
ha politizado la justicia los
partidarios del ex presidente están
convencidos de que el fbi trabaja para
la administración demócrata algunos de
ellos se reunieron frente a la sede de
la policía federal en esta ciudad al
este del país
es hora de deshacerse del fbi
necesitamos algo mejor algo responsable
lo peor del fbi es su arrogancia
donald trump ha estado rodeado de casos
judiciales desde que dejó el cargo
principalmente por su rol al incitar a
una horda de seguidores a tomarse el
capitolio en enero de 2021